[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і давайте
повеселимось з англійською привіт Пол привіт Ольга як справи
сьогодні
я добре сьогодні добре, я готовий говорити
більше про Великобританію Я ніколи не можу
перестати говорити про Великобританію, тому
що це  добре, добре, хлопці, ми
його готуємо, а ви робите це гірше, щоб
вам було трохи легше з цим
уроком, і, як я обіцяв, я
зробив для вас вікторину, тож, будь ласка,
перейдіть за цим посиланням і вивчіть ці слова
після уроку  вони обов'язково
знадобляться під час цього уроку,
тому будь ласка, будьте дуже уважні, а
після уроку, будь ласка, перейдіть за
посиланням і вивчіть ці слова, тому сьогодні
ми поговоримо про символи
Великобританії, а перше слово - банк свят
свято що це таке, що всі
люблять державні свята людоед, зазвичай це
понеділок, і це схоже на державне
свято з багатьох причин, але ніхто не
працює, у всіх є вихідний, і тому у
вас субота, неділя та понеділок немає
роботи довгі вихідні довгі вихідні  Чудово,
у травні у нас багато святкових днів,
єпископ Єпископ, це релігійна
людина в церкві, перший рівень
проповідника буде називатися священиком, тому
єпископ є вищим рівнем, ніж проповідник,
свого роду вікарним священиком з вищим рівнем
рівні, тож вищий священик є єпископом добре,
тоді приходить петлиця я не маю
я не маю петлиці сьогодні біля
петлиці був би на костюмі чи
піджаку, де можна витягнути квітку
квітку добре тоді йде нарцис
нарцис це  квітка це
національна емблема Уельсу, нарцис,
зазвичай вони білі або жовті,
добре, тоді йде оборона, це,
очевидно, для того, щоб зупинити атаку, щоб захистити
себе, щоб тримати щось подалі від вас,
тому наша армія - це наш захист так добре, тоді
це приходить  лицарство добре, мене
ще не посвятили в лицарі, на всяк випадок, коли
королева слухає, але це коли ти
стаєш сером, то ти стаєш на коліна
перед королевою, вона кладе меч на
твоє плече, і тебе
посвячують у лицарі, тому що  Ви зробили щось
надзвичайне для країни, як я бачу, тому,
коли ви лицар, ви холодний, сер,
так добре, тоді відбувається витік,
це національна їжа Уельсу, і вона скоріше
схожа на велику цибулю, о, я бачу цю товсту
цибулю  як густа зелена цибуля, яка є
в супермаркеті так добре,
тоді приходить дворянин
дворянин ну Благородний насправді означає, що у
вас високий рівень моралі, ви
хороша людина, хороший громадянин, тому дворянином
був би хтось із хорошою репутацією
мм-хм  потім приходить покровитель і художник,
вони як наші святі, тому
святі країни, тому хтось, хто піклується
про країну, так, зазвичай, може бути
релігійним, тоді приходить чистота, чистота,
тому якщо ви знову чиста людина, у
вас хороший рівень моралі мм-хм  а потім
йде трилисник трилисник
це національна квітка національна
емблема Північної Ірландії, і я думаю,
це принесе вам удачу, якщо ви знайдете не три,
а чотири листки цього
трилисника, а саме чотирилисник, о, це
не загальне  капелюх не церемонія,
це чотирилистник конюшина чотирилистий
конюшина, як квітка, ага, зазвичай
вільні листки, але іноді чотири листки, так що
це удача так само, як якщо б ви розбили
яйце, а іноді у вас було два
жовтки.  так, моя мама сказала мені, що
це пощастило,
я бачу, як хлопці помічають, що
між трилисником і
конюшиною є різниця, це різні рослини, я бачу
добре, тоді як би ви вимовили
це слово свист свисток свисток, ви
повинні бути обережні, торкаючись до офіційних осіб,
тому що вони мають  кілька гострих моментів, але
офіційно це національна квітка
національна емблема Шотландії добре,
наступне слово, яке потрібно враховувати, розглядати це означає,
як ви вважаєте, що щось добре, а
наступний є вертикальним. Сьогодні я стою дуже
вертикально, тому це означає, що Пол
вертикально правий  добре, давайте перенесемо один, тому,
хлопці, сьогодні ми проведемо
урок аудіювання, і ви будете
слухати, і ви повинні заповнити пропуски,
щоб Пол представив аудіювання,
слухайте уважно, і ви будете  послухайте кожен
уривок двічі добре
послухайте, Пол, візьміть свої зошити і
будь ласка, запишіть свої відповіді, ласкаво просимо,
Пол добре, тому Сполучене Королівство
скорочено від Сполучене Королівство
Великої Британії та Північної Ірландії –
це політична назва країни, яка
складається з Англії Шотландії Уельсу та
Північної  Ірландія добре ще раз
Сполучене Королівство, скорочено від
Сполучене Королівство Великої Британії та
Північної Ірландії – це політична
назва країни, яка складається з Англії
Шотландії Уельсу та Північної Ірландії,
прапор Сполученого Королівства, відомий як
Юніон Джек, складається з вільних
хрести прямостоячий червоний хрест на білому
тлі хрест сера
Джорджа покровителя Англії білий
діагональний хрест на синьому
фоні хрест Сан Андрія
покровителя Шотландії червоний діагональний хрест на
білому тлі хрест  якогось
Патріка,
покровителя Північної Ірландії, тому
знову хлопці прапор Сполученого
Королівства, відомий як  Юніон Джек
складається з вільних хрестів прямостоячий червоний
хрест на білому тлі
хрест сина Георгія покровителя
Англії білий діагональний хрест на
синьому фоні хрест якогось
Андрія, покровителя Шотландії
червона діагональ  хрест на білому тлі
- це хрест якогось Патріка,
покровителя Північної Ірландії Гей, а
наступний грає валлійський прапор, який називається
валлійським драконом, представляє справжнього дракона
на біло-зеленому фоні і
знову валлійський прапор під назвою валлійський
дракон  представляє червоного дракона на
білому та зеленому фоні добре, хлопці,
тепер ми готові перевірити їхні відповіді,
тому перше слово – ні ніж, а потім
із Богом складається понад добре, давайте подивимося
далі, і ось у нас вертикальна вертикаль Червоного
Хреста, а потім на білому
тло, а потім у нас є
святий покровитель Ірландії, так, і наступний
прапор – це валлійський прапор, який називається валлійський
дракон, що представляє червоного дракона на
біло-зеленому фоні  ви,
валлієць, наполовину валлієць, наполовину добре, добре,
хлопці, ви знаєте, що Пол пообіцяв мені щось
минулого разу, коли він пообіцяв привезти дракона,
тому що Пол наполовину валлієць, тому Пол,
де твій дракон, я ношу свого дракона
для йоги, тому я подумав, що це було
б трохи  як плоска криниця
ні, але ти не пам'ятаєш,
що два уроки тому я сказав тобі, що одне з моїх
найбільших хобі - кулінарія, тому я завжди
готую і думаю про Уельс,
я так добре бачу, що це дійсно добре,
дякую, Пол, що привів свого дракона
до класу  добре, хлопці, давайте продовжимо
Пол, у нас тут багато квітів,
троянда, трилисник, нарцис, і ще раз
це слово будячок свист так, і ми
отримали назви країн добре, чому я
вважаю, що це завдання для студентів,
а який вид  завдання, можливо, вони
повинні відповідати квітам до країни,
відповідати квітам до країни, тож ви
маєте на увазі, що країни мають квіти, оскільки
є символи так, національні
герби о, я бачу, хлопці, як ви
думаєте, троянда відповідає тому, що думає
країна  про Північну Ірландію та Уельс
Я думаю, у тих, хто був уважним, може
бути така ідея, тому що Пол уже розповідав нам
про деякі квіти, які можуть
бути символами цих країн, добре,
давайте подивимося, щоб троянди підійшли до
Англії та офіційні матчі до Шотландії
тоді  у нас є жовтий нарцис для
Уельсу та Північної Ірландії, задихає свій
трилисник, хлопці, наступне
завдання на прослуховування буде про ці
символи, тож що вам потрібно зробити, ви
повинні послухати і сказати
, правдиві чи хибні
твердження, перегляньте ці твердження  ви
почуєте прослуховування двічі в перший раз,
ви почуєте прослуховування двічі
вдруге, ми дозволимо вам слідувати
цьому сценарію разом з Павлом, але в
перший раз просто послухайте і спробуйте сказати
правда чи неправда, щоб день Юрія припав
на  23 квітня і вважається
національним днем Англії, у цей день деякі го
ді англійці носять згортки, приколоті до
іджаків, че
вона троянда є національною емблемою Ан
лії з  Під час Війни
троянд у XV столітті День святого Андрія
30 листопада вважається
національним днем Шотландії. У цей день деякі шо
ландці носять розщеплювач у пе
лиці як національний герб Шо
ландії.  15 століття, як
символ оборони, орден
розщеплених є одним із вищих лицарських орденів,
заснований у 1687 році і в
основному був наданий через шотландського дворянина
св.  День Давида першого березня -
це церковне свято св.  Давид, єпископ 16-го
століття, покровитель Уельсу.
Цей день вважається національним
святом Уельсу, хоча він не є
офіційним святковим днем у цей день, пр
те багато валлійських чоловіків носять жовтий на
цис або цибулю-порей, прикріплений до куртки, ос
ільки обидві рослини тр
диційно є  вважається національним гербом Уельсу
вул.  День Святого Патрика 17 березня
вважається національним днем у Північній Ір
андії та офіційним банківським святом. На
іональний герб Ірландії - це трилисник, а з
легендою це була рослина, об
ана Святим Патріком для іл
страції християнського вчення про Тр
йцю Ірландців.  добре, хлопці, а тепер, будь ласка,
слідкуйте за Павлом, і ви можете бачити
текст на екрані, тому слухайте і слідкуйте за
ним у читанні День Святого Георгія припадає
на 23 квітня і вважається
національним днем Англії в цей день деякі го
ді англійці  носити троянду, прикріплену
до піджака червона троянда є національною
емблемою Англії з часів
Війни троянд у 15 столітті
День святих євреїв 30 листопада
вважається національним днем Шотландії в це
день деякі шотландці носять ро
щеплюється  у петлиці як національна емблема
Шотландії, мабуть,
вперше розщеплюється в 15 столітті як
символ оборони, орден
ділиться є одним із найвищих лицарів  hood
і він був заснований в 1687 році і в основному передається
через шотландського дворянина вул.
День Святого Патрика 17 березня
вважається національним днем у Північній Ір
андії і є офіційним державним св
том. Національний герб Ірландії тр
лисник був, за легендою, ро
линою, обраною святим Патріком дл
ілюстрації християнського вчення пр
Трійцю до ірландської св.  День Давида
першого березня – це церковне
свято св.  Давид, єпископ шостого століття,
святий покровитель Уельсу. Цей день
вважається національним святом в
Уельсі, хоча в цей день це не державне свято,
проте багато чоловіків Уельсу
носять шпильки або куртки з нарцисами або цибулею-порею, оскільки
обидві рослини вважаються національними
емблемами  Уельс
добре, хлопці, тож ви прослухайте текст
двічі, чи готові ви стверджувати
, правдиві речення чи хибні, давайте подивимося
на перше st.  День Георгія припадає на
23 квітня і вважається
національним днем Англії, правда це чи не
равда, ви повинні знати, звичайно, я зн
ю, і зовсім недавно це о так, Да
, це твердження вірне, ви бачите, що воно зе
ене, наступне грає st.  День Андрія
31 жовтня Павло Я думаю, що
31 жовтня – це інше свято,
так, це свято Хеллоуїна,
так, і це не
національний день Шотландії, ні, ні, тому це
твердження є хибним, тому наступне свято.
День Патріка 17
Мардж Я вважаю, що це
правильне
так, дуже відоме свято, 17
березня, так, добре, і він позначений зеленим,
а останнє свято, яке надіслано, День Давида, 1
березня, це церковне свято, відправте
Давиду шосте-  століття єпископ,
покровитель Уельсу, чи це правда, коли він падає, я думаю,
що це абсолютно вірно,
давайте подивимося, так, це правда, тож у нас є
лише один падіння у цій вправі,
давайте продовжуємо, тому хлопці, ваше домашнє завдання, ви
повинні заповнити цю таблицю, тому  у вас є
прапори, покровителі, чай пам’яті та
квіти, тому, якщо вам потрібно прослухати
текст ще раз, зайдіть на YouTube і
прослухайте його ще раз, і ви зможете отримати
всю необхідну інформацію з цих
текстів,  будь ласка, заповніть цю
таблицю та надішліть її нам на нашу електронну пошту або
в Instagram, і Павло має пропозицію
завдання це завдання для вас,
ви знаєте, я люблю давати вам завдання,
тому в Україні весна розквітає багато
квітів, тому ваше завдання
сфотографувати наступний т  o одна з цих квіток, щоб
ваше обличчя і квітка мали
прилягати один до одного, подивіться, чи зможете ви
знайти всі чотири квіти, це
проблема, тому що я не впевнений щодо
будяка, чи ми все ще зможемо знайти його в
Україні в травні, але можливо  тому ті, у кого
є фотографії з усіма цими квітами
, наступного разу отримають щось від нас добре,
давайте, Пол, ти готовий до
драматичної закуски я завжди готовий до однієї з
твоїх закусок,
Ольга, так, і цього разу ми
будемо мати  закуска з мандамуса
справжня,
але перед тим, звичайно, ми повинні
перевірити домашні завдання добре, хлопці
, ви пам’ятаєте домашню довіру, яку ми
вам надали минулого разу, тому ми зупинилися на
реченні про вагітну жінку, щоб вона
збиралася народити дитину
подивіться та перевірте свої відповіді
[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ви готові грати з нами,
тому я думаю про майбутнє, ми
візьмемо кілька M&M з пакета, і кожен
колір буде представляти різні аспекти
майбутнього ми повинні будемо скласти
речення відповідно  до кольору
цукерки, наприклад, якщо у вас зелена
цукерка, складіть речення про свої
плани, якщо у вас є жовті рішення на місці,
тож інші правила діють
прямо й чітко, добре, давайте подивимося на такий
жовтий колір на даний момент безперервно
і трохи про те, що це таке, ви
повинні пам'ятати, що з попереднього
уроку, тому ми використовуємо поточний безперервний для
чогось, що вже влаштовано або
вирішено, потім червоний колір для ваших планів або
передбачення з доказами, а потім
зелений колір для передбачення
без доказів  або рішення на місці
, пропозиції та обіцянки добре,
хлопці, так жовтий червоний і зелений, тягніть свою
чергу,
виберіть цукерку, тому Пол, якого кольору у вас
є у мене зелена цукерка, так що Ден є
передбаченням без доказів, я не буду
пити пиво сьогодні ввечері, добре  немає пива для Пола
сьогодні ввечері добре
Майк Ензі о, я почервонів, тому плани та
рішення я збираюся прочитати книгу
сьогодні, це мій план, добре, у мене є
жовта цукерка, так що це
вже щось прийнято чи домовлено я  я зустрічаюся з
друзями завтра мм-хм
добре, наступний для мене,
тому зелений зелений
це передбачення без доказів або
рішення на місці хм, я думаю, що я
з'їм його прямо зараз червона цукерка мм-хм червона
для  плани та рішення я збираюся
з'їсти курку два вогники, тому що я
вже приготував її мм-хм, є
свідчення в єгиптян, я бачу, все гаразд,
наступний у мене жовтий, тому це
фіксований план або дата, о, я  я викладаю
п'ять уроків у понеділок, тому це фіксований
план я вчитель і я викладаю п'ять
уроків у понеділок так, у мене також є
жовта цукерка, я також викладаю в понеділок,
але я працюю не так важко, як Ольга
лише два уроки в понеділок,
щасливі, що ви Павло добре, хлопці, тому я думаю,
ви зрозуміли ідею цієї гри, тому візьміть
трохи цукерок і пограйте в цю гру, використовуйте
майбутній час і практикуйтеся якомога більше
, тому що практика робить ідеальним, і
це кінець  наш урок, Павло,
що ти думаєш про цей сьогоднішній урок,
мабуть, найкращий урок  тому що ми
отримали цукерки
Ольга так добре, хлопці, так що пам'ятайте
про домашнє завдання, опублікуйте свої фотографії та отримайте,
можливо, цукерки від нас з Павлом
до побачення
[Музика]